here's the first thing that might
surprise audiences about hard kill the
low budget action drama is low-key
killing it with a stronger than expected
showing on netflix leave it to the
streaming masses to show the film
critics of the world that they just
don't understand
fun if you were given the basic plot
summary a hardened deck special forces
mercenary is hired by a tech billionaire
to save his kidnap daughter
and safeguard a potentially world
shattering piece of mcguffin software
which one would you guess bruce willis
was playing okay so he's not the
kidnapped daughter but neither is he the
mercenary in this instance
that part goes to jesse medcap 23 years
younger than willis and more tolerant of
the hits and punishment that come with
being an action star
that leaves willis as donovan chalmers
corporate ceo and scarf enthusiast
capable of running a company that delves
vaguely into ai and quantum computing
does that sound complicated and perhaps
a little sci-fi it's really neither
hard kill is about as uncomplicated an
action movie as you can find on netflix
which is why its chart-topping dominance
comes as a bit of a surprise
in hard kill written by chris lamont and
joe russo not the joe russo you're
thinking of willis's chalmers and
medcap's derrick miller team up to
rescue his daughter and the software
from the hands of a terrorist mastermind
who's known to gare
is the partner well this is certainly
the film's big above the title
star while there's no escaping the title
intentionally reminiscent of die hard
the movie is actually its own thing
entirely
amazingly this is willis's third
collaboration with director matt
esquindari over the last two years after
2019's trauma center and 2020 survived
the night
none of these cinematic outings have
exactly dazzled though survive the night
was arguably the best received out of
the trio
hard kill presents a lot more of the
same from this thrifty and pecan
partnership so if you like the first two
chances are good you'll find something
to enjoy in the third
medcap is a veteran of prime time soaps
who's carved out a second career as a
low-budget action and horror hero
he played gardner-turn lover john
rolland on abc's lynchy and suburbian
gothic desperate housewives and grieving
parent turned vengeful punisher craig
landry in 2010's the torture
he starred as christopher ewing on the
reboot of dallas and has chased carter
in the two movie adaptations of the dead
rising video game series
he was trace riley and chesapeake shores
and luke graves in escape plan 2
hades you get the idea along for the
rider lala kent is charmer's kidnapped
daughter eva
and wwe star eva marie as miller's
teammate sasha zindel
actors texas battle and sergio rizzuto
returned from trauma center to play ally
nick box and the villainous partner
respectively
hard kill is unlikely to win any critics
choice awards this year
it has a zero percent rating from just
18 reviews on rotten tomatoes
with most of those reporting that
willis's performance is somewhere on a
spectrum from exhausted to the stainful
frank scheck of the hollywood reporter
said the production notes inform us that
the unimaginatively titled hard kill was
filmed in a mere 10 days
making you wonder how they spent eight
of them the guardians mike mccahill
wrote in a one star review
look beyond the lifelessly choreographed
shootouts and you keep catching glimpses
of ghosts
those of american industry yes but also
those of the american action movie
once manufactured with a skill verve and
wit holy absent from these painfully
long 98 minutes
anyone hoping bruce willis might enjoy a
career renaissance after his rediscovery
in m night shyamalan split in glass
lower those expectations now of course
there's a certain niche a movie like
this is trying to hit and close
examination for the purpose of writing a
review isn't quite it
while the film has undoubtedly withered
under the critical gaze it's actually
above water with the fans
for what it's trying to be hard kill
appears to be more successful than the
scathing reviews let on
it holds an audience score of 67 on
rotten tomatoes and judging by how it's
doing on netflix lots of people are
willing to at least give it a shot
you could be the next convert check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite tv shows and movies are coming
soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one